Trascrizione: Gianluca Finocchiaro
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno a tutti,
il mio nome è Alberto Broggi.
Vengo dall'Università di Parma
dove un paio di anni fa
abbiamo lanciato una spin-off
che si occupa di ingegnerizzare
le idee che sviluppiamo
in ambito universitario.
La presentazione di oggi, l'avrete visto,
l'ho intitolata
"Sulle orme di Marco Polo".
Il motivo spero che sarà chiaro
verso la fine della presentazione.
Comunque, per introdurre
quello di cui mi occupo,
oggi ho pensato di inziare dalla fine.
Voglio mostrarvi un filmato.
Inizierei con un filmato.
Vi chiedo di dare un'occhiata se c'è
qualcosa di strano in questo filmato.
Non focalizzate l'attenzione
sulla macchina,
sulla vettura blu davanti,
ma sulla vettura dietro.
È un filmato che abbiamo realizzato
3 anni fa, uno dei primi filmati
che ritraggono la nostra
tecnologia al lavoro.
Se notate, non c'è nessuno a bordo.
Questo è quello di cui ci occupiamo,
cerchiamo di togliere
il guidatore dal veicolo.
A dire la verità anche
di aiutare il guidatore,
comunque l'obiettivo finale
è di togliere il guidatore.
Come mai facciamo questo?
Ho portato un paio di numeri,
per spiegare il motivo
per cui noi ci occupiamo
di questa tecnologia.
Il primo è questo: 40.000 sono i morti
nelle strade europee all'anno.
Ma il dato più impressionante
è che più del 90%
di questi incidenti
è dovuto a cause umane.
Quindi non è il veicolo che si rompe,
ma è il guidatore che
non è capace di guidare,
è sotto l'influenza di qualche
sostanza, oppure si distrae.
Quindi non è il veicolo, ma è l'uomo.
Quindi quello che cerchiamo di fare
è dare intelligenza al veicolo,
così che possa aiutare il guidatore
o magari un giorno addirittura
rimpiazzare il guidatore.
Quindi, se vogliamo riassumere,
l'obiettivo principale che abbiamo
è di aumentare la sicurezza stradale.
Questo è uno degli obiettivi principali,
poi ce ne sono tanti altri.
Ad esempio, se pensate di avere un veicolo
capace di muoversi senza nessuno
a bordo, senza guidatore,
questo veicolo potrebbe anche essere
collegato ad altri veicoli
oppure ad un'infrastruttura stradale
dalla quale può ottenere informazioni,
come ad esempio la mappa del traffico,
quindi potrebbe scegliere
la strada migliore.
Oppure potrebbe essere in grado
di evitare alcuni punti
in cui ci sono già
degli ingorghi o incidenti.
Insomma potremmo avere un'ottimizzazione
dell'infrastruttura globale.
Quindi potremmo avere
un incremento dell'efficienza
dal punto di vista del carburante.
Il veicolo sa modulare la velocità, è in
grado di scegliere la velocità migliore,
la strada migliore quindi porta
a destinazione in meno tempo possibile.
Ma non solo: un veicolo
del genere potrebbe, ad esempio,
dare mobilità a chi non ha mobilità,
come ad esempio le persone anziane
oppure i giovani
che non hanno ancora la patente.
Oppure anche chi è affetto
da qualche handicap di mobilità.
Vi faccio vedere adesso dove abbiamo
applicato questa tecnologia finora.
Questi sono alcuni veicoli su cui abbiamo
implementato questa tecnologia
che permette al veicolo di guidare
senza nessuno a bordo.
L'abbiamo implementata
su automobili, autovetture, camion,
mezzi pesanti -ma non solo,
anche su altri tipi di veicoli.
Come, ad esempio,
veicoli agricoli quali i trattori,
veicoli per il movimento terra,
veicoli per il lavoro stradale.
Vi faccio giusto un esempio:
pensate di avere questa tecnologia
su un trattore che è in grado, ad esempio,
di muoversi da solo
su un campo, 24 ore al giorno,
7 giorni su 7, senza nessuno a bordo,
ed effettua tutti i lavori del campo.
E pensate agli appezzamenti
di terreno estesissimi
del Brasile, dell'Argentina, della Cina.
Qualcuno addirittura dice
che, utilizzando queste tecnologie
di automazione estrema del lavoro,
si riuscirebbe ad ottimizzare
del 250% l'utilizzo della terra.
Quindi vorrebbe dire avere
una produzione alimentare estesissima,
che potrebbe scatenare una rivoluzione,
perché potremmo veramente garantire
cibo per tutto il globo.
Questo è un esempio.
Vi mostro adesso
qualche filmato di alcuni veicoli
che abbiamo sviluppato
nella nostra storia.
Nel 1998 abbiamo percorso
praticamente mezza Italia,
2000 km in modalità automatica.
Nel 2005 abbiamo attraversato
il deserto del Nevada,
sempre con un veicolo senza guidatore.
Nel 2007 abbiamo fatto un test
all'interno di una città.
Questi sono soltanto alcuni degli esempi
dei veicoli che abbiamo
sviluppato nel passato.
Il presente?
Questo è un veicolo che abbiamo a Parma
adesso, sul quale abbiamo installato
tutta la tecnologia
che ci veniva in mente.
Abbiamo installato
10 telecamere -nascoste -
sono 10 telecamere,
4 laser scanner, 16 fasci laser,
GPS, radar, tutto quello
che ci veniva in mente.
Questo veicolo riesce a muoversi da solo.
Vede di fronte,
capisce l'ambiente e reagisce.
E questo veicolo l'abbiamo
portato a Roma 2 anni fa.
Abbiamo provato a fare un test.
Siamo partiti dal Campidoglio
e siamo scesi fino al Colosseo
senza nessuno a bordo.
Quindi il veicolo guidava da solo
ed è stato in grado
di localizzare gli ostacoli, evitarli,
frenare di fronte ai pedoni, gestire
gli altri veicoli che erano sulla strada
ed è stata una dimostrazione fenomenale,
molto interessante e di successo.
Ma la domanda che tutti
ci hanno fatto è stata:
Ok, funziona, l'abbiamo dimostrato,
siamo riusciti ad arrivare in fondo;
ma è veramente affidabile,
funziona davvero
in tutte le condizioni stradali,
meteo, di traffico?
Quella volta ci è venuta
un'idea un po' pazza:
proviamo a fare qualcosa
di un po' diverso.
Proviamo a mettere questa tecnologia
su veicoli e mandiamoli lontano.
Facciamo dei test sul viaggio più lontano
che possiamo fare, il viaggio più lungo.
L'anno scorso l'Expo Mondiale
era a Shanghai,
e allora abbiamo deciso va beh,
mandiamo i nostri veicoli all'Expo,
facciamo vedere questa tecnologia
all'esposizione mondiale.
Però l'idea è stata- ok, mandiamoceli,
non è che ce li portiamo.
Abbiamo fatto partire i veicoli da Parma
e i veicoli se ne sono andati
da soli fino a Shangai.
Il motto di questo viaggio è stato
13.000 km, 3 mesi di viaggio,
nessuno alla guida.
Ed è successo l'anno scorso
da fine luglio fino a fine ottobre.
Meno di un anno fa siamo arrivati.
È stato il primo viaggio nella storia,
viaggio intercontinentale
percorso da veicoli senza guidatore,
senza nessuno.
L'obiettivo vero di questa cosa
era testare la nostra tecnologia.
Vedere se funziona
e magari se non funziona
localizzare esattamente dove non funziona
per poi metterla a punto,
lavorarci poi in laboratorio
per mettere a punto e limare il sistema.
Vi faccio vedere il veicolo
che abbiamo utilizzato.
Questo è un veicolo così come è uscito
dalla fabbrica, un veicolo elettrico.
Non è ibrido, è elettrico completamente.
Questo, invece, è la fotografia
dello stesso veicolo
così come è risultato
dopo il nostro intervento.
Abbiamo aggiunto un po' di sensori
e abbiamo trasformato
il veicolo da elettrico
a elettrico-automatico,
che guida in automatico, senza guidatore.
Dicevo, il vero motivo di tutto questo
è stato un test della tecnologia.
Però effettivamente la nostra visione,
che volevamo portare,
la nostra visione del futuro è questa.
Un giorno, magari, potremo anche
voler trasportare della merce
da un punto all'altro del globo,
e potremo farlo senza guidatore,
quindi senza operatore umano
e magari anche senza benzina,
perché in questo caso
abbiamo utilizzato veicoli elettrici
con un pannello solare,
che si ricaricavano -- ricaricavano
il nostro sistema di guida --
quindi un giorno potremo avere
una mobilità sostenibile
nel senso che potremo portare merce
da una parte all'altra del globo
senza intervenire, diciamo,
sull'ambiente e sull'energia.
Vi mostro adesso, brevemente,
che cosa vede il veicolo.
Il veicolo riconosce gli ostacoli,
riconosce la carreggiata,
riconosce il terreno come è fatto,
localizza qual è la zona
in cui si può muovere.
Una volta percepito l'ambiente
prende decisioni,
quindi decide dove muoversi e se
può accelerare, frenare, sterzare.
Prima di partire abbiamo fatto
un certo numero di test,
a Parma e nelle vicinanze di Parma,
in tutte le condizioni
che ci venivano in mente,
perché non avevamo la minima idea
di quale potesse essere
la struttura dell'ambiente
che avremmo trovato durante il viaggio.
Non sapevamo se avremmo incontrato
strade sterrate,
fuoristrada, asfaltate o il tipo
di infrastruttura stradale.
Non ne avevamo la minima idea,
non potevamo testare prima e poi rifarlo.
Ci abbiamo messo tre mesi.
Abbiamo fatto test dappertutto.
Questa è una fotografia
che mostra, qualche giorno prima
-abbiamo quattro veicoli- i nostri
quattro veicoli col mio gruppo di ricerca.
Qualche giorno prima di partire
noi eravamo a Parma.
Partenza da Milano, fine luglio dell'anno
scorso, siamo partiti da Piazza Duomo.
I primi passi che ha percorso
il nostro veicolo
sono stati scortati dai Carabinieri,
appunto in Piazza Duomo.
Poi qualche fotografia che vi mostra
alcuni passi di quest'avventura.
È stata un'avventura dal punto
di vista tecnico, sicuramente,
ma anche dal punto di vista
della logistica, delle infrastrutture.
Abbiamo passato la Russia, parte
dell'Europa e della Russia,
con temperature elevatissime.
Alcuni tratti di questa avventura
sono stati percorsi di notte.
Abbiamo incontrato
un meteo di tipo diverso.
Abbiamo oltrepassato
zone di lavori in corso,
ma anche di infrastrutture mancanti.
Fintanto che siamo arrivati addirittura
a dei passi di montagna in Cina,
siamo arrivati quasi a 3000 metri
con questi veicoli.
Insomma, quel che abbiamo fatto
è stato immergere
la nostra tecnologia
nella infrastruttura reale.
Abbiamo fatto un test
non artificioso, ma reale.
Siamo entrati nelle strade reali
con infrastrutture reali,
con meteo reale e traffico reale
e questa è stata la cosa
più importante per noi,
perché siamo riusciti effettivamente
a testare la nostra tecnologia.
Fintantoché poi siamo arrivati all'Expo.
Siamo riusciti ad entrare
all'esposizione mondiale,
abbiamo fatto una parata
al termine del nostro viaggio.
E queste sono un paio di fotografie
che abbiamo scattato durante la parata,
quindi mentre i nostri veicoli si stavano
muovendo all'interno dell'Expo.
Vi faccio vedere soltanto
il tragitto completo
che abbiamo percorso l'anno scorso.
Forse adesso riuscirete a capire come mai
ho intitolato la mia presentazione
"Sulle orme di Marco Polo":
non tanto per il fatto
che il tragitto è simile a quanto
aveva percorso Marco Polo,
la via della seta, ma quanto perché
mi piacerebbe che questa avventura
somigliasse alla rivoluzione
che ha portato Marco Polo,
che ha messo in contatto
due culture diverse,
la cultura europea e la cultura asiatica.
Questo tipo di tecnologie, sono sicuro,
le vedremo a breve sulle nostre strade.
A breve vuol dire 5-8 anni da adesso.
Magari su strade specifiche,
come ad esempio autostrade,
con infrastrutture molto amichevoli.
Probabilmente, se vogliamo pensare
di avere queste tecnologie
sul veicolo che guida sulla strada urbana,
magari dovremo aspettare ancora
15 anni, ma 15 anni non sono tanti.
Se pensate che l'autovettura è stata
inventata più di 100 anni fa,
15 anni non è tanto, ci stiamo arrivando.
La visione che ho del futuro
in questo campo è che sicuramente
- tra non so quanti anni, 10-20 anni-
noi entreremo nel nostro veicolo,
digiteremo la destinazione,
il veicolo ci porterà a destinazione
automaticamente, senza nessuno alla guida.
Noi scenderemo e poi, magari, il veicolo
si va a parcheggiare da solo.
Magari anche fuori città, o magari rimane
disponibile per un altro utente.
Quindi il tipo di mobilità sarà una
mobilità completamente diversa,
sarà una rivoluzione perché
si passerà, io ne sono certo,
da una mobilità personale, quindi non
sarà più un veicolo di proprietà,
ma sarà un veicolo condiviso,
come avere dei taxisti
o dei taxi sempre disponibili,
sempre puntuali
che hanno una conoscenza assoluta
di tutto l'ambiente circostante.
Questa è la mia visione del futuro.
Grazie.
(applausi)